einen schönen guten tag ihnen und hier
steht brüssel mit weiß christel mit
erkennen sie das mal ganz stark abhängig
christel netz das kommt bei markus söder
nicht auf den tischen das sagt ja ganz
klar und deutlich beim cdu parteitag in
hannover wir mal rein da ging es
hingegen um eine gabe von drogen
gefahren bin dagegen
ich bin dagegen soweit alles noch ok
sagen ja wie cannabis reicht nicht
sondern dann muss jetzt kokain und
crystal meth
crystal meth also markus söder und sein
crystal meth dieses wort hat karriere
gemacht an diesem wochenende und der
politische gegner kommentiert das sofort
karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister was sagt er
zur legalisierung von crystal meth das
also ist der kommentar von karl
lauterbach zu diesem markus söder er
sagt erstmal bleibt bei der
legalisierung von cannabis weil er nicht
glaubt dass das zur verbreitung von
crystal meth führen wird
achja bleiben verschont das wäre eine
schlechte nachricht für alle vegetarier
wenn alle plötzlich crystal meth
abhängig wären also weit der
bundesgesundheitsminister aber auch im
netz geht es natürlich rund crystal meth
allein der hashtag der trend natürlich
also von crystal meth weil ich ja gerne
abhängig mit zwiebeln hier hatte ich
gebe mich nicht das macht nicht abhängig
noch mehr reaktion tausende waren es am
wochenende die sich plötzlich mit
crystal meth auseinandergesetzt haben
auch dass hier das erst im lederhosen
report kommt der titel noch mal ganz
groß rausgekommen gleich auch noch mal
ins spiel also im netz ging es wirklich
hoch und runter alle machten sich lustig
naja crystal meth jetzt stehen der
begriff markus söder kommt crystal meth
nicht auf den tisch
[Musik]